>> Tyra: PREVIOUSLY
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE JOURNEY BEGAN
FOR 20 SEMI-FINALISTS
IN LOS ANGELES.
>> Christina: I'M JUST
A SMALL TOWN GIRL
HERE IN THE BIG CITY.
>> Katie: I WANT THIS SO BAD.
>> Tyra: BUT FOR THE TEN
LUCKY FINALISTS, THE ADVENTURE
CONTINUES IN NEW YORK.
(car horn honking)
>> Adrianne: (screaming)
>> Tyra: THE GIRLS CHECK OUT
THEIR PENTHOUSE SUITE...
>> Robin: WE'RE GONNA NAME
OUR ROOM "THE DIVA ROOM."
>> Tyra: AND EACH OTHER.
>> Robin: DO YOU BELIEVE
IN ANYTHING, ELYSE?
>> Elyse: I'M AN ATHEIST.
>> Robin: ATHEIST?
>> Tyra: A BIKINI WAX
PREPARES THE GIRLS
FOR THEIR FIRST ASSIGNMENT.
>> Robin: THERE'S ONLY TWO
PEOPLE THAT'S BEEN DOWN THERE--
MYSELF AND MY GYNECOLOGIST,
AND I GIVE HIM CRAP.
>> Tyra: AN OUTDOOR
SWIMSUIT SHOOT ON
THE COLDEST DAY OF THE YEAR.
>> Adrianne: I SAY
IT'S ABOUT 20 DEGREES.
>> Douglas: SHE NEEDS TO BRING
SOMETHING TO THE TABLE.
I DON'T HAVE TIME TO SIT THERE
AND TEACH A MODEL.
>> Tyra: AND IN
THE FIRST ELIMINATION,
TESSA FROM CHICAGO
IS ASKED TO LEAVE.
NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
>> Robin: LET ME SEE YOUR
FAMILY.
>> Shannon: THAT'S MY SISTER.
>> Robin: OH, SHE IS SO CUTE.
>> Shannon: IT WAS REALLY
ACTUALLY HARD FOR ME LAST NIGHT
BECAUSE I WAS THE ONE
WITH TESSA AT THE ELIMINATION.
SO I WAS, LIKE, I REALLY THOUGHT
THAT I WAS GOING TO BE LEAVING.
I HAVE MY CONFIDENCE BACK
RIGHT NOW, SO WE'LL SEE
HOW THE NEXT ELIMINATION GOES.
>> Ebony: YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
>> Shannon: OH, THANKS.
>> Ebony: ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
THE GIRLS ARE GREAT,
AND THEY'RE DEFINITELY
FITTING IN, SO I'M EXCITED.
COME ON, Y'ALL!
OKAY. WE'RE DIVAS.
>> Elyse: I REALLY JUST WANT
TO GET AWAY FROM EVERYBODY
RIGHT NOW.
THE OTHER GIRLS ARE JUST...
AT THIS HIGH VOLUME,
HIGH ENERGY ALL THE TIME.
>> Ebony: THAT WOULD BE CUTE.
>> Shannon: I WANT THAT ONE.
>> Robin: NO,
I'M NOT GIVING YOU THIS.
THESE ARE MINE!
>> Elyse: I'M SO TEMPTED
TO JUST SIT IN HERE
AND BE AWAY FROM ALL THE NOISE.
>> Ebony: I HAVE A ROBE,
WHICH I'M WALKING AROUND NAKED,
AND THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
SEE ME IN MY THONGS.
>> Elyse: ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA STAY IN HERE
WITH THE DOOR LOCKED
FOR JUST A COUPLE MORE MINUTES.
♪♪♪
>> Adrianne: AS ALWAYS,
I WAS THE FIRST ONE
TO WAKE UP THIS MORNING.
LADIES, WAKE UP. IT'S TYRA MAIL.
>> Nicole: OH, GOD.
>> Giselle: DEFINITELY CURIOUS
TO WHAT'S IN STORE
FOR US RIGHT NOW,
BUT WHATEVER THEY HIT ME WITH,
I'M READY TO GO FOR IT
AND DO IT.
>> Adrianne: "YOU'RE ABOUT TO MEET YOUR FIRST
FASHION EXPERT,
WHO WILL HELP YOU
ON THE WAY TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BE READY AT 11:30 A.M."
EVERYBODY, DON'T EXCEED
OVER 15 MINUTES IN THE SHOWER.
>> Katie: LET ME KNOW
WHEN Y'ALL ARE DONE.
>> Adrianne: CAN I SHOWER
WITH YOU, ELYSE?
ELYSE IS A SLUT!
>> Ebony: YOU KNOW,
I'M VERY SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
WE'RE IN A COMPETITION,
AND MY PLAN IS TO WIN.
THERE IS NOTHING ELSE BUT THAT.
>> Nicole: YEAH, ACTUALLY.
BASICALLY...
>> Elyse: THERE WERE TIMES
THAT I FELT VERY UNCOMFORTABLE
BECAUSE I AM AN ACADEMIC,
AND I LOVE BEING AN ACADEMIC.
IT'S--I LOVE SCIENCE.
I APPLIED TO MEDICAL SCHOOL.
IT'S BEEN DIFFERENT JUST BEING
OUT OF MY NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> Adrianne: I WISH I COULD BE
ASLEEP.
>> Robin: MISS ELYSE.
COME HERE, SWEETIE. PLEASE?
>> Shannon: OH, GOSH.
>> Elyse: I AM A MILITANT ATHEIST,
AND ROBIN ACTUALLY SHOWED ME
THIS BIBLE VERSE--
"FOOLISH IS THE MAN
WHO SAYS THERE IS NO GOD."
THAT WAS A REALLY
FORWARD THING TO DO.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN GOD,
AND IT WAS OFFENSIVE.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M SUPPOSED TO THINK.
>> Robin: LIKE,
WHEN I READ THAT,
THAT MADE ME THINK OF YOU.
♪♪♪
>> Ebony: WHOO!
>> Tyra: HEY, Y'ALL!
>> Women: HEY! HI!
>> Tyra: HOW ARE YOU?
>> Women: FINE. GOOD.
>> Tyra: IT'S OBVIOUS
WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY, RIGHT?
>> Women: CATWALK.
>> Tyra: RUNWAY. CATWALK.
EVERY MODEL
HAS HER OWN PERSONAL STYLE,
AND THIS IS THE LAST EXAMPLE
OF MY PERSONAL STYLE RIGHT HERE.
♪♪♪
♪ BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL ♪
♪ THANKS AGAIN ♪
♪ HERE WE GO ♪♪
>> Tyra: THAT'S MY STYLE,
BUT THAT'S MINE,
AND YOU GUYS NEED TO FIND YOURS.
I KNOW, ROBIN, ON YOUR AUDITION,
YOU KINDA DID MY THING,
AND THAT'S FINE,
BUT THEN PUT ROBIN IN IT
AND FIND, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S YOU.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
RUNWAY DON'Ts.
NOW THIS IS A GIRL
WHO CAN'T WALK IN HEELS...
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: THE GIRL THAT THINKS
THAT SHE'S SEXY, BUT SHE AIN'T.
THIS NEXT ONE IS WHAT I CALL
"THE CHURCH FASHION SHOW."
>> Women: (laughing)
>> Tyra: WRONG!
(music stops)
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
I HAVE THE ONE AND THE ONLY
TOP RUNWAY TRAINER.
I HAVE KNOWN HIM
SINCE I WAS 17 YEARS OLD.
HIS NAME IS J. ALEXANDER.
COME OUT HERE, J.
>> Women: (cheering)
>> Tyra: THESE GIRLS ARE
EXTREMELY LUCKY TO HAVE J.,
THE DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE.
HE'S WORKED WITH ALMOST
EVERY TOP MODEL THERE IS
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
>> J.: ONE AT A TIME,
WALK DOWN AND WALK BACK
FOR ME, PLEASE.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: RUNWAY
IS LIKE SILENT THEATER.
IT IS THE ONE TIME THAT PEOPLE
GET TO SEE YOU MOVING.
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO KNOW HOW TO WOW THAT CROWD.
>> J.: OH! (gasps)
>> Adrianne: MY RUNWAY--
I SUCKED SO BAD.
>> J.: MOST OF YOU ARE WALKING
ALMOST TOO TIGHT IN THE BOOTY--
LIKE THIS.
YOU'RE TAKING SHORT STEPS.
YOU'RE NOT WALKING LIKE...
LIKE THIS.
KEEP YOUR EYES
LOOKING STRAIGHT AHEAD.
JUST HAVE YOU WALK
WITH SOME MUSIC BACK AND FORTH,
AND I'M GONNA START
MAKING SOME CORRECTIONS.
♪♪♪
>> J.: I THINK NICOLE HAS
A QUIET CONFIDENCE.
SHE WASN'T SURE ABOUT THE WALK,
BUT SHE HAS A QUIET CONFIDENCE.
MISS ROBIN IS THE PLUS SIZE.
SHE'LL BE GREAT
IN HER END OF THE BUSINESS.
ADRIANNE HAS THE RIGHT ELEMENTS.
WATCH HER FANCY FOOTWORK.
SHE'S TAKING IT IN VERY QUICKLY.
SHANNON--PRETTY FACE.
SOMETHING VERY COMMERCIAL
ABOUT HER WALK.
HAVE YOU DANCED BEFORE?
>> Giselle: YEAH.
>> J.: DANCERS ARE ALWAYS
QUITE DIFFICULT TO BREAK IN,
BECAUSE IT'S THIS...
>> Women: (laughing)
>> J.: KESSE, WHEN YOU WALK,
TAKE THE CENTER.
RELAX. JUST RELAX.
JUST--SO YOU DON'T STIFF.
EBONY'S TRYING TO STAND OUT,
AND SHE ALREADY STANDS OUT.
WALK WAS A BIT UPTIGHT,
BUT I'M TRYING TO BREAK HER IN.
>> Katie: I LOVE RUNWAY.
LIKE, IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT WAY
TO KINDA EXPRESS YOURSELF.
SOME GIRLS DON'T HAVE IT
NATURAL, AND I THINK
I HAVE THAT NATURAL WALK.
>> J.: KATIE--SHE'S INTO IT.
I MEAN, VERY, LIKE,
"IT'S ALL ABOUT ME.
I'VE ALREADY BEEN
TO THE LEVEL THAN YOU HAVE."
BUT, OF COURSE,
HER WALK NEEDS HELP.
THERE'S ONE GIRL FOR ME
THAT HAS WHAT IT TAKES.
WHEN I LOOK AT ELYSE,
I THINK THE BODY
IS RIGHT FOR CLOTHES.
>> Adrianne: THIS GUY KNOWS
WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
HE'S THE DIVA OF DIVAS.
THAT MAN BLEW ME AWAY.
>> J.: MY MOTTO IS
"WALK LIKE IT'S FOR SALE,
AND THE RENT IS DUE TONIGHT."
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
HOW TO WALK IN A TIGHT SKIRT.
♪♪♪
>> Nicole: J. WALKED OUT--
THAT LITTLE BLACK, LIKE,
UNDERWEAR OR SOMETHING
AND HIGH HEELS.
>> Shannon: JAY'S LEGS LOOK
A LOT BETTER THAN MINE DO,
SO, YEAH,
HE'S GOT SOME PRETTY SEXY LEGS.
>> Kesse: OH, MY GOSH.
IT WAS SHOCKING TO ME,
SEEING HIM IN THOSE HEELS,
BUT IF HE CAN WALK
IN THOSE PUMPS, I KNOW I CAN.
>> J.: YOU NEED
A PAIR OF HIGH HEELS,
'CAUSE THAT MAY CHANGE
THE WAY YOU WALK AS WELL.
>> Elyse: WALKING DOWN
THE RUNWAY WITH J. NEXT TO ME
IS DIFFICULT, BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE MOST OF THE INFORMATION
THAT WE GET FROM HIM
IS IN THE FACIAL EXPRESSIONS,
WHICH WE CAN'T SEE WHEN
WE'RE STARING STRAIGHT FORWARD.
THERE IS NO HOPE FOR ME
ON THE RUNWAY.
>> J.: WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO DO AFTER THIS?
>> Katie: I DEFINITELY WANT
TO PURSUE ACTING,
AND I REALLY WANNA DO TV.
>> Ebony: I, UM, SING.
I ALSO DO--
UM, I'M ALSO A COMEDIENNE.
>> Elyse: IF I DON'T WIN
THIS CONTEST,
START MEDICAL SCHOOL IN AUGUST.
>> J.: THAT'S A LOT OF WORK.
>> Elyse: OH, I KNOW.
>> J.: BOYFRIEND'S A DOCTOR.
>> Giselle: ELYSE--I LOVE HER,
BUT HER DREAM
IS TO BECOME A DOCTOR,
AND IT'S, LIKE, WELL,
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
THAT REALLY, REALLY
PISSES ME OFF.
>> J.: OKAY, GIRLS,
REMEMBER, YOU HAVE
THAT LITTLE TABLE AT HOME.
GET UP THERE AND DO YOUR THING.
SEE YOU LATER, BABY.
>> Women: THANK YOU! BYE!
♪♪♪
>> Ebony: IT'S THAT
NEW YORK THING.
STRETCH IT OUT, GIRL.
THERE WE GO.
I WANT A GOOD, CHEESY,
NEW YORK PIZZA!
>> Shannon: ALL OF THE GIRLS
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT ELYSE.
WHEN WE WERE EATING
AT THE PIZZA PLACE,
SHE GOT OATMEAL.
>> Adrianne: SHE DOESN'T REALLY
EAT AS MUCH
AS I WOULD CARE FOR HER TO.
>> Giselle: (belches)
>> Nicole: OH,
THAT WAS ATTRACTIVE.
WHAT DID YOU GUYS
THINK ABOUT HOW YOU DID TODAY?
>> Elyse: WE ALL NEED
A LITTLE SOMETHING TO WORK ON.
>> Nicole: YEAH, YOU WERE
THE ONLY PERSON HE DIDN'T GIVE
ANY--NOTHING.
>>Elyse: I THINK I PERFORMED
REALLY, REALLY POORLY,
AND I'M NOT USED
TO BEING INCAPABLE AT ANYTHING.
>> Giselle: IF YOU'RE
NOT GONNA STOP, KICK IT OUT
AND STOP LIKE THAT.
>> Nicole: THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING RIGHT NOW.
>> Giselle: YEAH, I KNOW.
>> Ebony: FIERCE. AND FIERCE.
I NEED MOTIVATION.
>> Nicole: RELAX, REMEMBER?
>> Ebony: RELAX. THANK YOU.
>> Elyse: I DO NOT HAVE THE WILL
TO WALK ON THE CATWALK
LIKE I GIVE A DAMN.
BUT I DON'T WANNA BE A MODEL.
I DON'T. I CAN'T.
AND IT'S SO--
OH, IT'S SO IRRELEVANT.
ELIMINATE ME.
DO IT.
♪♪♪
>> Shannon: I'M EXCITED
'CAUSE WE GET TO WORK
WITH J. ALEXANDER.
HOPEFULLY, HE'LL BE ABLE TO
TEACH ME SOME MORE THINGS
THAT I NEED TO DO
TO BETTER MYSELF.
>> J.: OKAY, GIRLS,
I HAVE A SURPRISE FOR YOU.
THERE'S GONNA BE
A LITTLE CHALLENGE,
AND IT'S GONNA BE CALLED
"EXTREME RUNWAY."
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA DO
A MOCK FASHION SHOW.
BACKSTAGE THERE'S
A BAG OF CLOTHING
WITH YOUR NAME ON IT,
AND YOU HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT CHANGES.
AND WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO--
WALK STRAIGHT OUT,
ONE BEHIND THE OTHER.
EVERY 10, 20 SECONDS,
ANOTHER GIRL.
STRAIGHT DOWN,
TURN AROUND AND COME BACK.
YOU WILL BE EVALUATED
ON THE THINGS THAT YOU LEARNED,
AND ONE OF YOU WILL BE REWARDED
WITH A NIGHT ON THE TOWN
WITH WYCLEF JEAN
IN THE RECORDING STUDIO.
>> Giselle: OH, MY GOD!
>> J.: WYCLEF JEAN,
YOU KNOW, WYCLEF?
>> Ebony: GOING TO SEE WYCLEF
IS THE BEST PRESENT.
I THINK HE'S BRILLIANT.
I WOULD LOVE TO MEET HIM.
>> Giselle: I HAVE TO
GO TO THIS.
I REALLY WANT TO GO TO THIS.
>> J.: OKAY, YOU HAVE TO CHANGE
AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
AND YOU'RE GONNA GO
IN THIS ORDER--
GISELLE, YOU'RE GONNA BE FIRST.
ADRIANNE IS NUMBER TWO.
KESSE'S NUMBER THREE.
>> Giselle: WHAT MAKES ME
REALLY NERVOUS--WE'RE GONNA BE
EVALUATED ON THE RUNWAY.
>> J.: AND REMEMBER,
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
GIRLS, FIRST OUTFITS, PLEASE.
GIRLS, HURRY UP.
>> Elyse: BACKSTAGE
THINGS WERE PRETTY CHAOTIC.
I THINK IT WAS
EVERY GIRL FOR HERSELF.
>> Giselle: WHAT'S FRONT?
WHAT'S BACK? I DON'T KNOW.
JUST STICK 'EM ON AND GO.
>> J.: LET'S GO.
GISELLE, I NEED YOU NOW.
WHEN THE GIRL TAKES OFF,
THE NEXT GIRL GOES RIGHT--
TAKES THAT POSITION.
YOU GOTTA COME NOW.
HURRY UP. NEXT.
♪♪♪
>> Adrianne: WHEN WE WERE
BACKSTAGE, I TOOK MY STUFF OFF.
I WAS BUCK NAKED.
I HAD TO GET INTO MY CLOTHES,
AND I HAD TO DO IT
IN 30 SECONDS.
>> Katie: I WAS TRYING TO
CONCENTRATE ON GETTING MYSELF
TOGETHER--PUTTING MY CLOTHES ON.
SO I TRIED MY BEST.
I DID GREAT.
>> Shannon: MY RED SHIRT THAT
I WAS SUPPOSED TO KEEP OPEN,
WHICH IF YOU JUST WALK,
IT'LL JUST SHOW THE WORLD
EVERYTHING, AND I DIDN'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
♪♪♪
>> Robin: THE HARDEST THING
WAS GETTING READY, LIKE,
REALLY, REALLY FAST.
>> Adrianne: I THINK WITH ROBIN,
SHE'S USED TO CHECKING HERSELF
OUT IN THE MIRROR,
WHICH MADE HER LATE.
>> J.: HURRY UP.
NEXT!
>> J.: THIS DRESS
LOOKS ACTUALLY NICE ON YOU.
IT ACTUALLY LOOKS...
IT'S SO YOU.
>> Elyse: FRANKLY, THIS DRESS
IS HIDEOUS, AND I AM SO GLAD
THAT I DON'T OWN IT.
>> J.: AND THAT IS VERY YOU.
POCAHONTAS MEETS "PLAYBOY"--
IT'S RIGHT THERE, BABYCAKES.
>> J.: KESSE, YOU WERE LATE.
YOU'RE SMILIN', BUT YOU KNOW
YOU WERE LATE MOST OF THE TIME.
AND, ELYSE, YOU MISSED YOUR SHOE
OR SOMETHING.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOUR SHOE?
>> Elyse: MOST OF THE TASKS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO, DO NOT
RELY AT ALL ON INTELLIGENCE.
AND BEING SMARTER
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS
DOESN'T GIVE ME ANY ADVANTAGE.
>> J.: MISS ROBIN, LATE.
CHECKIN' IN THE MIRROR.
>> Robin: IT WASN'T LOOKIN' IN
THE MIRROR THAT MADE ME LATE.
IT WAS AN OUTFIT CHANGE.
BUT IT STILL DIDN'T MAKE
A DIFFERENCE, I WAS STILL LATE.
FINE.
>> J.: SHANNON,
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO
LEAVE THE SHIRT OPEN,
BUT YOU CAME WITH IT BUTTONED.
>> Shannon: I DIDN'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH IT OPEN.
>> J.: YOU DIDN'T FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH IT OPEN,
BUT THERE WAS A WAY THAT YOU
COULD HAVE WALKED WITH IT.
YOU COULD'VE WALKED LIKE THIS.
NOW YOU KNOW THAT NOW.
>> Shannon: I'VE LEARNED A LOT
FROM HIM,
BUT I STILL NEED TO LEARN MORE
TO BECOME A BETTER MODEL.
>> J.: EBONY, YOU WERE LATE,
AND YOU ALSO CAME OUT EARLY
AT ONE POINT.
>> Ebony: I'M SORRY. I SHOULDN'T
HAVE WAITED.
>> J.: YOU HAVE A VERY STRONG
FACE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GIVE TOO MUCH
ATTITUDE.
>> Ebony: JUST BEING SO NEW
AND YOU SAYING, "OKAY, LET ME
FIND MY STYLE. LET ME FIND
WHAT I'M TRYING TO EXPRESS,"
I WANT TO SHOW THAT I'M CAPABLE.
>> J.: GISELLE, VERY WELL,
AND WORKED AN UGLY '80s DRESS
AND MADE IT LOOK
VERY, VERY MODERN.
GOOD FOR YOU.
ADRIANNE, YOU DID
QUITE WELL ACTUALLY.
KATIE, YOU DID WELL.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO BE
LESS SEX AND MORE PRESENCE,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IT'S JUST HOW YOU LOOK.
IT'S JUST HOW YOU'RE BUILT.
AND, NICOLE, YOU DID WELL, TOO.
SO I NEED YOU TO STEP FORWARD,
YOU TO STEP FORWARD,
YOU TO STEP FORWARD
AND YOU TO STEP FORWARD.
OKAY.
SO THE PRIZE GOES TO
MISS GISELLE.
>> Giselle: I NEVER
WIN ANYTHING.
>> J.: WELL, THERE'S
A FIRST TIME FOR EVERYTHING.
>> Giselle: I WAS JUST IN SHOCK.
I WAS LIKE...
(stammers)
"ARE YOU SURE?"
>> Adrianne: I DIDN'T AGREE WITH
J. THAT GISELLE DID REAL GOOD,
BECAUSE SHE REALLY DOESN'T HAVE
MUCH SELF-CONFIDENCE,
LIKE, AT ALL.
>> J.: I DON'T WANT YOU
TO GO ALONE, SO YOU GET
TO CHOOSE THREE FRIENDS...
>> Giselle: OH, MY GOSH.
>> J.: TO GO WITH YOU
FOR THAT NIGHT IN THE STUDIO
WITH WYCLEF JEAN.
>> THANK YOU.
SINCE YOU GUYS WERE
HERE WITH ME, YOU THREE.
>> Adrianne: I THINK EBONY
TOOK THE RUNWAY SHOW LETDOWN
A LOT HARDER THAN MOST.
>> Elyse: HER JAW WAS CLENCHED.
SHE DIDN'T SAY A WORD TO ANYBODY
FOR--FOR ONCE.
>> J.: SO ANYWAY, GIRLS,
ENOUGH SAID.
HAVE A WONDERFUL TIME,
YOU FOUR, THIS EVENING.
♪♪♪
>> Adrianne: I SO WANNA
HANG OUT THE WINDOW,
YELL AT SOMEONE, BE LIKE,
"HEY, LADY, EVER GET YOUR...
LICKED BY A FAT MAN
IN AN OVERCOAT?"
THAT'S MY FAVORITEST LINE EVER
FROM A MOVIE--
JAY AND SILENT BOB.
OKAY, MISS ELYSE
DOESN'T WANT TO TALK.
SHE'S BUSY.
>> Elyse: ALIENATION
FROM THE OTHER GIRLS
REALLY AFFECTS MY DESIRE
TO BE IN THE COMPETITION.
>> Ebony: I ASKED THEM
TO BRING US SOME WATER.
I'M PRAYING THEY DID.
>> Adrianne: YOU GUYS,
WE HAVE ITALIAN DRESSING?
>> Shannon: DUH.
WHAT DID I COME IN HERE FOR?
>> Adrianne: CAN I
JUST SMELL IT?
>> Ebony: EXCUSE ME.
>> Shannon: OH.
>> Adrianne: IS THIS LOW-FAT?
OH, NO.
>> Katie: I CAN SEE YOU
AS, LIKE, A MAKEUP MODEL.
>> Giselle: YEAH.
>> Katie: REALLY FRESH, YOUNG,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> Nicole: I FEEL
THE SAME WAY.
IT'S LIKE, I REALLY WANNA...
>> Elyse: THERE ARE
THE MOST VAPID CONVERSATIONS
YOU'VE EVER EXPERIENCED
GOING ON ALL AROUND ME
ALL THE TIME.
>> Adrianne: I HAD NO IDEA.
>> Elyse: ADRIANNE,
STOP INTERRUPTING ME.
STOP QUOTING JAY AND SILENT BOB
RIGHT NEXT TO MY EAR.
I'VE HAD ENOUGH OF YOU.
ROBIN, HOW (bleep) DARE YOU
SHOW ME THAT "FOOLISH AS THEE"
ATHEIST BIBLE VERSE
THIS MORNING AND ASK ME
WHAT DO I THINK OF IT.
WHAT THE (bleep) AM I SUPPOSED
TO THINK OF IT?
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK OF YOU?
FOOLISH IS A WOMAN WHO BELIEVES
THAT (bleep) DAMN TRIPE.
GISELLE, YOU (bleep)
WORTHLESS (bleep).
YOU ARE SO WASTEFUL,
BITCHY, STUPID.
YOU'RE WORTHLESS.
YOUR PARENTS MUST BE
ASHAMED OF YOU.
J., YOU OFFENDED ME TODAY.
I KNOW AT THE MEDICAL SCHOOL
IT'S HARD WORK.
HOW CAN I POSSIBLY
NOT BE AWARE OF THAT?
IT TAKES A (bleep) ASS
TO COVER EVERY SEAT,
YOU (bleep) SLICE.
KATIE, I DON'T BELIEVE A WORD
THAT COMES OUT OF YOUR MOUTH.
YOU'RE THE MOST INSINCERE PERSON
I'VE EVER MET.
DAMN IT.
LET ME (bleep) DIE.
YOU BITCHES.
>> Giselle: WE DID
A RUNWAY COMPETITION,
AND I DID WIN THE COMPETITION.
I'M GONNA BE GOING TO
WYCLEF JEAN'S RECORDING STUDIO.
I'M SO EXCITED.
>> Katie: WE WERE, LIKE, KIND OF
THE RUNNERS-UP, SO ME AND NICOLE
AND ADRIANNE GOT PICKED TO GO.
>> Kesse: I'M DISAPPOINTED
BECAUSE I REALLY WANNA GO.
I REALLY DO.
>> Elyse: I REALLY DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT THE PRIZE
FOR THE RUNWAY CHALLENGE.
I WAS VERY, VERY GLAD
TO HAVE THE HOUSE TO MYSELF
FOR A FEW MINUTES.
>> Adrianne: BYE, Y'ALL.
>> Kesse: BYE, HAVE FUN.
>> Adrianne: THANKS, DUDE.
>> Robin: YOU KNOW,
THIS IS REALLY GONNA SUCK,
'CAUSE NOW IT'S JUST US.
>> Shannon: OH, MY GOSH.
>> Ebony: GIRLS!
EMERGENCY! LETTER. I'M GONNA
READ IT.
>> Elyse: DO WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR
EVERYBODY?
>> Ebony: YEAH, NO, WE DON'T.
WE'RE HERE.
COME ON LADIES,
Y'ALL ARE HERE.
WHOEVER'S HERE.
OH, NO.
>> Elyse: "LADIES, YOU'LL BE
UNDERTAKING YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
WITH--"
>> Shannon: 7:30 IN THE MORNING.
>> Elyse: "LADIES, YOU WILL BE
>> SORRY.
UNDERTAKING YOUR SECOND PHOTO
SHOOT WITH 'STUFF' MAGAZINE
TOMORROW MORNING.
BE READY TO GO IN THE APARTMENT
AT 7:30."
>> Ebony: WHEN WE GOT THE NOTE,
WE WERE LIKE, "WELL, THE OTHER
GIRLS ARE ALREADY GONE."
AND SO THEN WE SAID,
"WELL, OKAY, WE'RE GONNA GO DOWN
AND TELL THEM."
WELL, ROBIN, YOU KNOW, "HEY,
I'M GOING DOWN TO GET THEM."
YOU KNOW, GREAT, FABULOUS.
YOU BE THE ANGEL FOR TODAY.
I SAID I WOULD NOT HAVE
WENT DOWNSTAIRS TO TELL THEM.
>> Shannon: WE GOT A LETTER
SAYING, "LADIES, YOU WILL BE
UNDERTAKING A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH 'STUFF' MAGAZINE
TOMORROW MORNING."
>> Nicole: WHAT?!
>> Shannon: "BE READY TO GO
IN THE APARTMENT AT 7:30."
>> Nicole: WHAT?
>> Giselle: I JUST GOT A HUGE
PIMPLE ON MY FOREHEAD, JEEZ.
>> Robin: LOOK,
THIS IS WHAT IT IS.
THIS IS "STUFF."
THIS IS THE MAGAZINE.
OH, MY WORD.
♪♪♪
>> Katie: WYCLEF--
I'VE ALWAYS LIKED HIM.
I'VE ALWAYS LIKED HIS MUSIC.
>> Giselle: SO IS HE
EXPECTING US?
>> Katie: SURPRISE! (chuckles)
HI, NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> Wyclef: I'M WYCLEF.
HOW YOU DOIN'?
>> Giselle: GISELLE.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> Adrianne: ADRIANNE.
YO, WHAT'S UP?
>> Nicole: NICOLE.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> Wyclef: IS THIS A DREAM OR REALITY?
>> Nicole: I'M
ABSOLUTELY THRILLED.
IT'S THE BEST TIME EVER.
>> Wyclef: HERE WE GO.
>> Katie: ♪ DO ♪
>> Nicole: ♪ RE ♪
>> Adrianne: ♪ MI ♪
>> Giselle: ♪ FA ♪
>> Wyclef: AH'IGHT, BOO-YAH!
>> Giselle: WE'RE
SO NOT SINGERS.
>> Katie: I FEEL SO BAD FOR
THE GIRLS THAT ARE BACK HOME,
BECAUSE THEY WOULD PROBABLY
LOVE THIS.
>> Kesse: IF IT'S NOT COMPLETELY
NUDE, THAT'S MY ONLY, LIKE--
>> Robin: OKAY, OKAY, WHAT ABOUT THESE?
>> Shannon: NO. NO.
>> Kesse: YOU AIN'T SHOWIN'
NOTHIN' BUT YOUR BUTT.
>> Wyclef: ♪ AND IT WAS ♪
♪ ON KEY, MAN ♪
♪ LIKE A PRETTY FACE ♪
♪ I SEE HER SAYIN' ♪
♪ "OH, MY GOD" ♪
♪ SO I GOT NO TIME TO WASTE ♪
♪ THIS IS ♪
♪ DO ♪
♪ RE ♪
♪ MI ♪
♪ FA ♪
♪ THAT'S WHAT ♪
♪ I'M TALKIN' 'BOUT ♪
♪ MODELS SINGIN' ♪
♪ IN PLATINUM STUDIO ♪
♪ BROOKLYN ♪
♪ HERE WE GO AGAIN ♪
♪ DO... ♪♪
>> Robin: GOOD NIGHT, DIVA.
>> Kesse: GOOD NIGHT, FOXY.
>> Ebony: I WANNA PRACTICE THE RUNWAY.
I'M NOT PERFECT,
AND I'M NOWHERE NEAR IT.
I HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO,
A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
♪♪♪
>> Katie: I HAD
THE BEST TIME OF MY LIFE.
I NEVER THOUGHT THAT THIS WOULD
HAPPEN, LIKE, MEETING WYCLEF.
>> Adrianne: TONIGHT WAS PRETTY
FRICKIN' COOL, BEING ABLE TO
HANG OUT IN A RECORDING STUDIO
WITH WYCLEF.
♪♪♪
>> Adrianne: YOU KNOW, DUDE,
I'M BEAT.
SO WE HAVE TO
BE READY AT 7:30.
I WAS GETTIN' BAD VIBES
FROM EBONY,
LIKE SOMETHING REALLY SHADY.
SHE TOLD ME STRAIGHT UP
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Ebony: THE MAIL HAD CAME,
AND BASICALLY I WAS THE ONE
THAT FOUND THE MAIL.
IT WAS ACTUALLY
AFTER Y'ALL LEFT.
I GOT THE LETTER FIRST.
NOBODY WAS AROUND ME.
MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE
KEPT IT TO MYSELF.
>> Adrianne: I WOULD NEVER HAVE
DONE THAT MYSELF.
>> Ebony: RIGHT, BUT I WANT YOU
TO LISTEN TO ME.
DID I DO THAT?
>> Adrianne: NO.
>> Ebony: NO, BUT LISTEN
TO WHAT I'M SAYING.
I WASN'T GOING DOWNSTAIRS
AND LET THEM KNOW.
IT'S A COMPETITION.
>> Adrianne: EBONY WAS PLANNING
ON KEEPING TO HERSELF
THE TYRA MAIL SAYING THAT WE HAD
A "STUFF" PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
>> Ebony: INTERESTING, YOU TAKE
WHAT YOU WANNA TAKE FROM THAT,
BUT YOU KNOW.
>> Adrianne: THAT'S FINE.
I'M NOT UPSET ABOUT IT AT ALL,
'CAUSE I KNOW I'M GONNA DO
A GREAT JOB TOMORROW.
THAT'S WHEN IT FINALLY SUNK IN,
"HEY, THIS GIRL COULD HAVE
COMPLETELY RUINED MY CHANCES."
>> Ebony: MM-HMM.
♪♪♪
>> Robin: I MEAN, I WAS, LIKE,
THEY WERE GETTING THE WORD
"COMPETITION," LIKE, MIXED UP.
IT'S A GOOD COMPETITOR
AND A CONNIVING,
SNEAKY COMPETITOR.
LADIES, 'CAUSE Y'ALL WEREN'T
HERE AND WE WERE HERE,
AND LAST NIGHT EBONY SAID
THAT SHE WOULDN'T HAVE COME DOWN
THERE AND LET Y'ALL KNOW
THAT WE HAD A LETTER UP HERE.
THE COMPETITIVE PERSON
DID NOT COME DOWN THERE.
THE CHRISTIAN PERSON
CAME DOWN THERE.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
IN A GOOD COMPETITOR
AND A COMPETITOR
THAT HAS BAD VIBES.
AND ONE PERSON CAN GIVE, LIKE,
THE WHOLE HOUSE A BAD VIBE.
>> Ebony: I WASN'T PURPOSELY TRYING TO HOLD IT TO MYSELF,
AND I'M NOT GONNA
EXPLAIN THAT AGAIN.
IF YOU WANNA TAKE THAT ENERGY
AS THOUGH I REALLY MEANT
NOBODY WAS GOING DOWNSTAIRS,
YOU GUYS WERE NOT GONNA KNOW,
THEN THAT'S FINE.
>> Kesse: I WAS LIKE, "YOU WERE
THE SAME ONE THAT TOLD ME
THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU WOULDN'T
TELL 'EM ANYTHING."
>> Robin: YOU KNOW WHAT?
THOSE DEMONS THAT YOU HAVE
WITHIN YOURSELF
ARE GOING TO COME OUT,
AND YOU GONNA WONDER WHY NOBODY
WANTS TO BE AROUND YOU.
>> Ebony: I MADE IT CLEAR
FROM THE GET-GO,
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
I FEEL AS THOUGH YOU GUYS
MIGHT EXPECT CERTAIN THINGS.
I DON'T FEEL AS THOUGH
THIS IS A HIGH SCHOOL
OR A GROUP SESSION.
I LOOK AT IT, I ANALYZE IT--
>> Nicole: THAT'S NOT GONNA--
>> Ebony: EXCUSE ME.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYIN' TO SAY.
EXCUSE ME,
BUT I'M GIVING YOU MY OPINION
AND YOU'RE CUTTING ME OFF.
>> Elyse: EBONY WAS JUST OFF
ON HER RANTS THAT SHE GOES ON.
>> Ebony: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
AGREE WITH ME, THAT'S THE THING ABOUT A COMPETITION.
>> All: (talking at once)
>> Ebony: THAT'S RIGHT.
EXCUSE ME.
>> Adrianne: EVERYONE, JUST SHUT UP!
IT WAS BASICALLY
EVERYBODY FREAKING OUT SO LOUD
THAT NOBODY--EVEN IF YOU WANTED
TO SAY SOMETHING, YOU CAN'T.
SHE WON'T LISTEN TO YOU.
>> Ebony: YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Adrianne: La la la la la la.
>> Ebony: THIS IS
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
BEING A GROWN WOMAN.
YOU HAVE AN OPINION YOU WANNA
SAY, I DEFINITELY WANNA HEAR IT.
BUT CUTTING ME OFF
IS NOT GONNA WORK.
>> Robin: (singing)
>> Ebony: I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
ANYBODY CAN NOT...
DID I MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR?
>> Adrianne: ROBIN
STARTED SINGING.
>> Giselle: I DIDN'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS REALLY
GOING ON WITH THAT EITHER.
>> Robin: (singing)
>> Ebony: EXCUSE ME.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
I'M TALKIN' AND YOU'RE SINGIN'
IN THE MIDDLE OF ME TALKING.
>> Robin: ♪ HOW ♪
♪ HOW EXCELLENT ♪
♪ EXCELLENT ♪♪
>> Ebony: THAT
REALLY MIXED ME UP.
I REALLY DID NOT KNOW HOW TO RESPOND TO THAT.
THAT WAS LIKE, "WHOA."
>> Robin: EVERY HEAD BOWED
AND EVERY EYE CLOSED.
>> Elyse: ROBIN SORT OF
CALMED EVERYONE DOWN
BY MAKING US ALL SAY A PRAYER.
>> Robin: PEOPLE ARE TAKING
THE WORD "COMPETITIVENESS"
AND ARE TURNING ITS DEFINITION
AROUND, LORD.
AND, LORD, I ASK
THAT YOU REMOVE
ANY NEGATIVE THING THAT IS--
ANYTHING THAT IS NOT LIKE YOU,
THAT IS NOT OF YOU,
AND, LORD,
ONLY ONE PERSON CAN WIN
AND THE AWESOME THING ABOUT IT
IS THAT YOU ALREADY KNOW WHO THAT IS.
LORD, GIVE US
A CLEAN SPIRIT, LORD--
PURE AND WHOLE, JESUS.
CLEAR OUR MINDS, LORD.
>> Elyse: I WAS REALLY EMOTIONAL
DURING THE PRAYER
BECAUSE I WAS SO UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH THE ENTIRE SITUATION.
>> Robin: AND DON'T LET US LOOK
TO BE VINDICTIVE
AND CATTY AND SELF-RIGHTEOUS
AND ALL OF THOSE OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE OF DEMONIC PRESENCE,
AND, LORD, YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO BELIEVE IN ORDER TO KNOW
THAT IT'S JUST ABOUT BEING
A GOOD PERSON, LORD.
AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT
FASHIONABLE BEING A GOOD PERSON
AND BIND SATAN, JESUS.
AMEN AND AMEN.
>> Ebony: AND WHEN IT COMES
TO PRAYER, I WILL ALWAYS
HOLD HANDS AND HOLD.
BUT, ROBIN, THIS IS NOT
A BIBLE STUDY PROGRAM.
THIS IS NOT A, UM, SORORITY.
I'M SORRY.THIS IS A MODEL
COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
>> Shannon: WE HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR "STUFF" MAGAZINE.
>> Katie: "STUFF" MAGAZINE--
THAT'S MY DREAM TO BE
ON A COVER, THAT'S MY STYLE.
THE SEX APPEAL AND STUFF,
THAT'S JUST ME.
>> Nicole: IF I MADE IT
TO BE ON THE COVER
OF "STUFF" MAGAZINE, MY FRIENDS
ARE GONNA BE THRILLED.
>> Tyra: AS YOU GUYS KNOW,
YOU'RE DOING "STUFF" MAGAZINE TODAY.
THE ONE THING THAT YOU GUYS
MIGHT MAKE THE MISTAKE OF IS
THINKING THAT IT'S A MEN'S
MAGAZINE, SO YOU HAVE TO...
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT.
AGAIN, IT'S RIGHT HERE.
CAN YOU REALLY GET THAT MAN
TO BUY THIS MAGAZINE
BY JUST YOUR EYES
AND JUST THE SEXINESS
THAT YOU FEEL FROM INSIDE
AND THE BODY
WILL FOLLOW THE EYES.
SEE, I'M GONNA GO FIRST.
AND YOU GUYS CAN WATCH ME.
AND YOU CAN WATCH THE SEXINESS
COME FROM MY EYES.
>> Barry: GOOD.
BEAUTIFUL LIKE THAT.
THAT'S EXCELLENT.
TYRA COMES ONTO THE SET
AND SHE ENERGIZES
THE ENVIRONMENT,
MAKES IT VERY EASY FOR ME.
THAT'S WHY THESE BIG GIRLS
GET USED OVER AND OVER AND OVER.
IT'S WORTH ITS WEIGHT IN GOLD.
>> Kesse: I MEAN, I SAW HER
DOIN' HER THING OUT THERE.
>> Barry: YEAH, THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> Kesse: THAT'S A TOUGH ACT
TO FOLLOW.
>> Tyra: AND JUST, YOU KNOW,
MAKE DIFFERENT
FACIAL EXPRESSIONS.
TRY RAISING ONE EYEBROW.
TRY, YOU KNOW, THIS AND THIS
AND ALL JUST TYPES OF THINGS
TO SEE WHAT WORKS WITH YOUR FACE
AND YOUR BODY THE BEST.
PRACTICING THE POSIN'.
>> Katie: VICTORIA'S SECRET,
HERE WE COME.
>> Shannon: SHAZAM!
>> Barry: GOOD.
LIFT YOUR FACE UP A LITTLE BIT.
COME AROUND TO ME.
>> Katie: THE PICTURES THAT I'VE
TAKEN IN THE PAST WERE MORE ON
THE SEXY SIDE.
I DID "PLAYBOY" MAGAZINE.
I'M SURE SOME OF THE GIRLS
WOULD BE SHOCKED.
>> Barry: NO, THAT DOESN'T WORK.
JUST WARM IT UP A LITTLE BIT
IN YOUR EYES.
THAT LAST STUFF WE JUST DID,
THAT'S NICE.
LOOSEN THAT HAND UP.
IT'S TOO--
A LOT OF GIRLS ARE BEAUTIFUL.
BUT WHEN YOU TRY TO PHOTOGRAPH
THEM OR THE WAY THEY PHOTOGRAPH
CAN SOMETIMES BE
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT.
THAT'S GOOD.
JUST BRING ME--NICE.
ADRIANNE WAS FANTASTIC.
SHE SORT OF MOVED LIKE A SNAKE.
VERY SLOWLY, SHE KIND OF
SLITHERED AROUND.
>> Elyse: I'M NOT OFFENDED
AT ALL THAT SOMEONE IS TRYING
TO ALTER THE SIZE OF MY BREASTS.
BECAUSE I JUST SPENT AN ENTIRE
HOUR IN HAIR AND MAKEUP
ALTERING THE SHAPE OF MY HAIR
AND THE COLOR OF MY FACE.
>> Barry: ELYSE--VERY DIFFERENT
FROM THE OTHER TWO GIRLS I SHOT.
SHE WAS MUCH MORE ANDROGYNOUS.
>> Elyse: I FELT
INCREDIBLY UNSEXY.
IT WAS UNCOMFORTABLE,
AND IT WAS SILLY, REALLY.
>> Tyra: DO YOU HAVE TO BE
COVERED ALL THE TIME?
LIKE, WHY CAN'T YOU...
DO YOU WANNA BE COVERED?
THIS IS SAYING,
"OH, I'VE GOT HIPS
SO I'M COVERING 'EM UP."
YOU DON'T NEED
TO COVER YOURSELF UP.
WHY ARE YOU CRYIN', ROBIN?
TALK TO ME. WHY ARE YOU CRYIN'?
ON VICTORIA'S SECRET
PHOTO SHOOTS, I'M
THE BIGGEST GIRL ON THE SHOOT,
AND I'M NOT COVERING MYSELF UP.
YOU'RE FLY.
YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE OF YOU,
NOT BECAUSE OF SOME ROBE
COVERING YOU UP.
SHE CAN WALK AROUND WITH THAT,
BUT ON SET,
SHE NEEDS TO TAKE THAT OFF.
♪ YES, I'M STRONG ENOUGH ♪
♪ I KNOW I'M STRONG ENOUGH ♪♪
>> Barry: NICOLE--GORGEOUS TO
LOOK AT, YOU KNOW.
FROM HEAD TO TOE,
SHE'S PHYSICALLY FLAWLESS.
THERE'S SOMETHING VERY MODERN
ABOUT HER, YOU KNOW?
I JUST--I REALLY LIKED HER
ENERGY.
I LOVED THE BLONDE GIRL.
I THINK SHE WAS GREAT.
>> Giselle: OW!
>> Barry: GISELLE--
SHE IS SO BEAUTIFULLY PRESENT
THE WHOLE TIME.
THIS INNER SEXUALITY
THAT COMES THROUGH IN GISELLE.
AGAIN, LIKE THAT.
GORGEOUS.
>> Kesse: I FELT A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE, YOU KNOW.
I REALLY WASN'T SURE
IF I WAS DOING IT RIGHT.
>> Barry: SHE WAS VERY, VERY
AWARE OF ALMOST EVERYTHING
ABOUT HERSELF.
BEING THAT SELF-CONSCIOUS,
IT WAS HARD TO GRAB A MOMENT
OF SPONTANEITY.
♪♪♪
>> Katie: WHAT IS IT?
"TOMORROW, EIGHT OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED."
>> Elyse: OOH.
>> Adrianne: UH-OH.
I HOPE NOTHING LIKE
THIS MORNING EVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
IT PISSED ME OFF.
>> Elyse: YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT PRAYER WAS
SO INAPPROPRIATE.
>> Adrianne: I'LL BE HONEST.
I KIND OF BLOCKED IT ALL OUT
AS MY OWN PRAYER.
>> Giselle: YOU GUYS,
I'M SCARED FOR TOMORROW.
♪♪♪
>> Elyse: I WONDER ABOUT
KESSE WINNING THIS CONTEST.
'CAUSE SHE'S... GOOD.
IS SHE GONNA WIN
'CAUSE SHE LOOKS LIKE TYRA?
'CAUSE THEN IT WOULD BE LIKE
TYRA JUST CHOSE ANOTHER TYRA.
I THINK THAT THE OTHER GIRLS
PROBABLY HAVE THE PERCEPTION
THAT I'M NOT TAKING
THE COMPETITION SERIOUSLY.
BUT WHAT THE OTHER GIRLS DON'T
KNOW IS THAT I MAY BE STARTING
TO TAKE THE COMPETITION MORE
SERIOUSLY THAN I'M LETTING ON.
♪♪♪
>> Giselle: COULD YOU DO WATER?
>> Elyse: DO YOU WANT PEPPERMINT
OR REGULAR BLACK TEA?
'CAUSE PEPPERMINT TEA IS HERBAL
SO IT DOESN'T HAVE ANY CAFFEINE.
>> Giselle: PEPPER TEA?
>> Elyse: PEPPERMINT.
I'LL MAKE YOU SOME.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DRINK IT.
THE PAST COUPLE OF DAYS
I WAS REALLY, REALLY IRRITABLE.
BUT I'VE HAD
A GOOD NIGHT'S SLEEP,
AND THAT'S JUST
WORKED WONDERS FOR MY MENTALITY.
>> Adrianne: ONE OF US
IS GETTIN' CUT TONIGHT.
AND OF COURSE, IT'S GONNA
SCARE THE HELL OUTTA ME
AND SCARE THE HELL
OUT OF EVERYBODY.
>> Robin: SO HAPPY
THAT I'M STILL HERE.
>> Kesse:I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO PRAY, AND JUST ASK GOD
TO GIVE ME CONFIDENCE.
>> Giselle: OKAY,
IF I GET ELIMINATED,
I'M GONNA BE REALLY PISSED OFF.
♪♪♪
>> Janice: WELL, WELL, WELL.
>> Tyra: THE TIME HAS COME
TO MAKE THE SECOND CUT
IN DETERMINING WHO'S GOING TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND TO REMIND YOU, THE WINNER
WILL RECEIVE A CONTRACT
WITH REVLON COSMETICS,
A FASHION SPREAD WITH
"MARIE CLAIRE" MAGAZINE,
AND A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP AGENCIES
OF THE WORLD--WILHELMINA.
WE WILL BE JUDGING
YOUR RUNWAY WALK
AND YOUR PHOTOS.
ONCE AGAIN, WE'VE GOT
OUR PANEL OF EXPERT JUDGES
TO EVALUATE YOUR PROGRESS.
FIRST, WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST TOP MODELS.
NEXT WE HAVE BEAU QUILLIAN,
THE FASHION EDITOR
AT "MARIE CLAIRE."
WE HAVE KIMORA LEE SIMMONS,
THE OWNER AND CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF SEXY WOMEN'S CLOTHING LINE--
BABY PHAT.
AND THIS WEEK'S GUEST
IS YOUR RUNWAY TRAINER--
MR. DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE--
J. ALEXANDER.
HE IS GOING TO TEST YOU
ON WHAT YOU LEARNED.
>> J.: SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO DO--BUTTON UP YOUR COAT,
TAKE YOUR POSITION THERE,
WALK TO ME.
TURN AROUND, WALK BACK,
TAKE OFF THE JACKET
AND WALK TOWARDS ME.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHT, ROBIN,
I LIKE THAT YOU STARTED
AND YOU JUST LOOKED FULL OF LIFE
AND JUST HAPPY.
BUT YOU WERE A LITTLE NERVOUS
IN TAKING THAT JACKET OFF,
AND YOU TOOK IT OFF
A LITTLE BIT TOO EARLY.
THE CLIENT WANTS TO SEE
WHAT THE JACKET LOOKS LIKE FIRST
WHEN YOU'RE COMING DOWN
THE RUNWAY.
AND THEN WHEN YOU TOOK IT OFF,
YOU KIND OF UNDID THE SLEEVE.
THE SLEEVE CAME INSIDE OUT.
>> Robin: IN MY HEAD,
I SAID, "OOPS."
>> Kimora: I DON'T REALLY THINK
THAT YOU NEED ALL THAT
EYE CONTACT--SIDE TO SIDE
TO SIDE TO SIDE.
>> Robin: BECAUSE OF PAGEANTRY,
YOU LOOK AT THE AUDIENCE
AND YOU TRY TO
BRING THE AUDIENCE TO YOU.
>> Kimora: THIS IS NOT
PAGEANTRY.
HIGH FASHION IS NOT A PAGEANT.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHT, ROBIN,
LET'S LOOK AT YOUR BEST POLAROID
FROM THE SHOOT.
>> Beau: BEAUTIFUL, THAT FACE
DOES NOT SAY "26" TO ME.
>> Janice: (gasps)
SHE'S 26? THAT'S A LITTLE OLD.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: I LOVED
YOUR VERY LAST POSE
AT THE END OF THE RUNWAY.
IT WASN'T TOO MUCH,
BUT IT WAS LIKE, BAM, I'M HERE.
>> Janice: I THINK THE ARM
ACROSS YOUR STOMACH IS PUSHING
YOUR BREASTS TOGETHER TO MAKE
THEM EVEN MORE BREASTY.
I WOULD'VE BEEN A LITTLE MORE
RELAXED WITH THE POSE.
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: I DID NOTICE
WHEN YOU GOT BACK
TO THE END AGAIN,
YOU WENT, BOOM,
FIFTH POSITION, DANCER.
>> Janice: IF I WERE A DESIGNER,
I WOULD JUST, LIKE, DIE,
BECAUSE WHEN
YOU TOOK THE COAT OFF,
YOU DON'T, LIKE, REVEAL
THE LINING OF THE COAT.
PEOPLE ARE STILL LOOKING
AT THE COAT.
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT YOU.
>> Tyra: THIS IS
YOUR TEST SHOT FROM THE SHOOT.
>> Kimora: IT'S A GREAT PICTURE.
I THINK IT'S VERY SEXY.
I THINK I'M A LITTLE BIASED
BECAUSE THOSE ARE MY SHOES
THAT WERE MADE FOR ME
BY MANOLO BLAHNIK, HONEY.
>> J.: YOU JUST LOOKED
LIKE YOU WERE CATCHING FLIES.
YOU DO THIS.
>> Tyra: YOUR MOUTH WAS OPEN
THE WHOLE TIME.
YOU'RE TRYIN' TO BE SEXY.
YOU'RE TRYIN' TO
"AH, I'LL SHOW YOU MY MOUTH.
YEAH, I'M SEXY."
AND YOU ALREADY ARE SEXY.
>> Janice: I THINK
THE PHOTOGRAPH
IS ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
I REALLY LOVE IT.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A 10
ON THIS ONE.
>> Shannon: THANK YOU
>> Kimora: WERE YOU
THINKING SEXY IN YOUR HEAD?
'CAUSE I THOUGHT YOU WERE DOING
A LITTLE OF THIS STUFF
I WAS SEEING.
>> Tyra: THINK A LITTLE BIT,
LIKE, LEFT, RIGHT, LEFT.
YOU KNOW, INSTEAD OF...
>> J.: DON'T THINK
ICE SKATING
>> Tyra: DON'T THINK ICE
SKATING.
>> Janice: JUST FLOW,
BABY, FLOW.
>> Tyra: IT'S NOT ICE SKATING.
>> Tyra: BUT YOUR FACE LOOKS
GREAT.
I LOVE HOW THE LIGHT
IS HITTING YOUR CHEEKBONE.
THAT VERY FIRST POSE
YOU STRUCK ON THE RUNWAY
WAS SO CATALOG.
IT WAS SO
NOT HIGH FASHION AT ALL.
YOU WERE, LIKE, LEAN BACK.
>> Janice: I LOVE THE WAY
YOU'RE HOLDING YOUR FACE
3/4 TO THE CAMERA.
YOUR SMILE IS PERFECT.
WHY COULDN'T YOU WALK
LIKE THIS PHOTOGRAPH?
>> Janice: TO ME,
IT WAS THE ABSOLUTE BEST WALK
THAT I'VE SEEN.
YOU TOOK THE COAT OFF--
PERFECTION.
YOU SLUNG IT OVER YOUR SHOULDER
LIKE YOU'VE BEEN DOIN' IT
YOUR ENTIRE LIFE.
>> Tyra: YOU IMMEDIATELY PUT
YOUR HANDS IN THE POCKETS.
THERE'S A WAY WITH MODELING
TO PUT YOUR HANDS
IN YOUR POCKETS
WHERE YOU KINDA
JUST REST THEM LIGHTLY,
BUT YOU DID IT
LIKE YOU WERE COLD.
>> J.: YOU JUST NEED
TO WALK AND NOT THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
>> Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
THAT YOU TOOK DIRECTION
REALLY WELL.
>> Janice: IN THIS SHOT
YOU LOOK REALLY SEXY.
>> Elyse: I DON'T REALLY LIKE
IT.
I DON'T LIKE MY FACIAL
EXPRESSION.
I HAD TO MAKE
MY SEXUALITY MAINSTREAM.
>> Kimora: YOU'RE AN EDGY GIRL.
THERE'S NO NEED TO TRY
TO TAME IT DOWN.
I STILL THINK
THAT YOU ARE VERY THIN
AND VERY PALE.
>> Janice: YOU NEED
A LOT OF WORK ON YOUR WALK,
MISS THING.
I'M REALLY SORRY.
I THOUGHT THE STEPS WERE SHORT
AND STACCATO.
YOUR ASS WAS GOING, YOU KNOW,
WIGGLE-WOBBLE, WIGGLE-WOBBLE.
>> J.: LONGER STEPS.
>> Tyra: I DON'T LIKE
THIS PICTURE, KATIE.
I THINK IT CHEAPENS YOU.
I THINK IT JUST MAKES YOU
LOOK LIKE JULY--
MISS JULY IN A CALENDAR.
AND YOUR PICTURE THE OTHER DAY
LOOKED A LOT MORE "FASHIONY."
♪♪♪
>> Tyra: I FELT LIKE YOU WERE
A LITTLE BIT UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH YOUR HANDS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU STARTED.
YOU KIND OF CUPPED THEM
AROUND YOUR HIPS,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO JUST
LET THEM BE FREE AND FLOWY,
LIKE, BY YOUR SIDES.
>> Kimora: YOU KNOW,
WHEN A GIRL IS WALKING,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO FEEL SEXY
AND WOMANLY AND, YOU KNOW,
BAM, BAM, BAM.
>> Janice: YOUR WALK DIDN'T FLOW
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
YOU NEED TO JUST CONSIDER
THE WHOLE STRUT AN EVENT.
AND IF YOU CAN'T TAKE
MY CRITIQUE ON THE FLOW,
YOU MIGHT AS WELL
TAKE ANOTHER JOB,
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU.
>> Tyra: LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT ONE OF YOUR PHOTOS FROM THE SHOOT.
>> Kimora: I THINK
IT'S AN AMAZING PHOTO.
I THINK YOU HAVE A GREAT BODY.
I ACTUALLY THINK YOU LOOK
A LOT LIKE TYRA IN THAT.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
THANKS, KESSE.
SO WHAT DO WE THINK ABOUT KESSE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HER
IN TERMS OF HER BREAKING DOWN
AND CRYING?
DO YOU THINK
THAT MEANS SHE'S WEAK?
>> Beau: HER BREAKDOWN RIGHT
THERE
DIDN'T SAY "CONFIDENCE."
>> Tyra: GISELLE?
I LIKE GISELLE.
YOU KNOW, I LIKE GISELLE
BECAUSE IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
SHE WANTS THIS.
>> Beau: BUT I THINK
SHE NEEDS TO TIGHTEN UP.
>> Tyra: SHE GOT A WIDE ASS.
>> Janice: IT'S KINDA WIDE.
>> Tyra: ELYSE. IN.
>> Kimora: OUT.
>> Janice: SHE CAN'T WALK.
>> Kimora: VERY THIN
AND VERY PALE. IRVING PENN,
AVEDON WOULD LOVE HER.
>> Tyra: KATIE. OUT.
>> Janice: OUT. OUT.
>> Kimora: IN.
>> Tyra: IT'S NOT ABOUT JUST
SEXY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT LOOKING LIKE
THE TOP "PLAYBOY" COVER MODEL.
>> Janice: NO.
>> Tyra: SHE WOULD MAKE
A GREAT MODEL
FOR SWIMSUIT CALENDARS.
>> Beau: SHE'S GREATLY IMPROVED.
>> Kimora: IN.
>> Tyra: NICOLE?
>> Janice: IN.
>> Kimora: OUT.
>> Tyra: IN.
>> Beau: THERE'S SOMETHING
A LITTLE BIT VACANT THERE.
>> Tyra: SHANNON?
>> Janice: I GOT BROWNIE POINTS
FOR HER ON THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK SHE PICKED UP.
>> Tyra: YEAH.
I JUST THINK SHE HAS A SMILE
THAT IS SO MAGNETIC.
>> Tyra: EBONY?
>> Janice: HER SMILE IS
FLAWLESS.
>> Kimora: I THINK EBONY'S
A LITTLE LOST, MAYBE IN BETWEEN,
IS SHE HARD OR SOFT?
>> Tyra: I THINK HER
EYES ARE TO DIE FOR.
>> Beau: I'M INTO IT.
>> Tyra: IN.
>> Kimora: SHE'S OUT.
>> Tyra: ADRIANNE?
>> Janice: OH, I LOVE HER.
>> Tyra: IN.
>> Kimora: OUT.
>> Janice: SHE HAS
WHAT IT TAKES.
I SEE IT. I FEEL IT.
>> Tyra: ROBIN?
THE RUNWAY WALK, SHE WAS
STILL STUCK IN THE CHURCH WALK.
>> Janice: IT'S SO HARD,
YOU GUYS. IT'S SO HARD.
>> Tyra: IT IS HARD.
IT'S SO HARD.
THE JUDGES
HAVE REACHED A DECISION.
THERE WERE NINE OF YOU LEFT
AND ONLY EIGHT PICTURES
IN MY HAND.
THESE EIGHT PICTURES REPRESENT
THE EIGHT WOMEN
THAT ARE ON THEIR WAY
AND THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SHANNON.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NICOLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
GISELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
ROBIN.
>> Robin: (whispering)
I'M NOT GONNA CRY, I PROMISE.
>> Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS, ROBIN.
I HAVE FOUR PICTURES LEFT
IN MY HAND.
ADRIANNE.
ADRIANNE,
THAT RUNWAY WALK, GIRL...
WERE YOU PRESENT IN CLASS?
>> Adrianne: YES, MA'AM.
>> Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GOING TO CALL
IS EBONY.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ELYSE.
ELYSE, FIRST OF ALL,
YOU ARE GORGEOUS,
STRUT YOUR STUFF,
TAKE YOUR COAT OFF RIGHT NOW.
>> All: (laughing)
>> Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
>> Elyse: THANK YOU.
>> Katie: I'M FEELING LIKE
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON.
I'M... I DON'T KNOW.
I'M FEELING CRAZY.
JUST, LIKE,
MY MIND IS GOING EVERYWHERE.
>> Tyra: I HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HAND.
CAN KESSE AND KATIE
PLEASE COME FORWARD?
>> Tyra: WHOEVER'S NAME I CALL
WILL GO ON
AND WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE OTHER PERSON
WILL BE ELIMINATED
AND MUST IMMEDIATELY
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND MUST GO HOME.
>> Tyra: KESSE, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> Kesse: STANDING
NEXT TO KATIE,
SHE IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S GONNA GET HARDER AND HARDER
EVERY TIME WE HAVE TO
SAY GOOD-BYE TO SOMEBODY.
>> Katie: I WAS, LIKE, SHAKING.
LIKE, I WAS, LIKE,
TRYING TO BREATHE,
AND I, LIKE, I COULDN'T BREATHE.
>> Katie: MY GOAL WAS TO GET
IN VICTORIA'S SECRET,
SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M GONNA DO ULTIMATELY.
I'LL BE ON THE COVERS
OF MAGAZINES.
YOU'LL SEE ME.
I FEEL KINDA SAD.
JUST LIKE, YOU KNOW,
I'M GONNA MISS EVERYONE.
SO... JUST DIDN'T REALLY WORK.
♪♪♪